c'est une nouvelle bataille dans la
guerre qui oppose l'iran aux etats-unis
5 tanker iraniens ont quitté le port de
bandar abbas dans leurs soutes du gazole
destiné au venezuela téhéran comme
caracas sont frappés par des sanctions
économiques américaines qui ont pour but
d'asphyxier leurs économies cette flotte
de navires ressemble donc à un véritable
cauchemar pour washington la maison
blanche voyant ces deux bêtes noires
s'associer pour des transactions
pétrolières selon un haut responsable de
l'administration trump les états unis
envisagerait de prendre des mesures
contre 7 exportations de carburant
iranien
vous devez vous poser la question quels
sont les intérêts de l'iran au venezuela
des indices récents et témoignent d'un
soutien étatique et militaire iranien il
cherche à obtenir un avantage
stratégique dans notre voisinage pour
contrer les intérêts des états unis
réaction de téhéran le lendemain le
ministre des affaires étrangères iranien
se tourner vers l'onu
dans une lettre adressée au secrétaire
général de l'organisation
il met en garde contre toute
intervention américaine visant les
cargaisons de carburant en route vers
caracas
les etats unis doivent cesser d'agir
comme un tyran au niveau mondial et
respecter les lois internationales
notamment le droit de naviguer librement
dans les eaux internationales
le même jour en conférence de presse son
porte-parole enfonce le clou
l'iran se dit prêt à riposter à une
éventuelle manoeuvre américaine contre
ces pétroliers les navires contiennent
du carburant et se dirige vers le
venezuela je ne connais pas leur
position géographique exacte comme je
les dis c'est navire opère dans le cadre
des échanges commerciaux totalement
légaux à l'égard desquels aucun obstacle
légal ne peut être opposée comme je les
dis si ces échanges déplaise aux états
unis
c'est leur problème nous espérons
également qu'ils ne prendront aucune
initiative stupide à ce sujet car il
serait alors confronté à une réaction de
l'iran par les pétroliers iraniens sont
attendues sur les côtes vénézuéliennes à
partir de vendredi seront ils stoppée
par la marine américaine entre les
etats-unis et l'iran au moins un des
deux pays devra faire correspondre ses
actes ou dix cours des derniers jours